we're working with CEOs of Fortune 500
companies and I got to see that everyone
is just human you know there isn't
anything that I can't do just because of
where I came from or because they
haven't done it before like I can take a
shot maybe I'll be successful you know
look at where these people came from
I mean Crosby I'm the CEO of bench and
I'm 29 and the poem that we really
wanted to solve was it just wasn't a
good way to get your accounting done if
you're a small business like you had to
hunt someone down you didn't know if
they were good and the ways it would get
done it was a lot of work and for
someone who maybe didn't know a lot
about accounting to begin with or was
the first time in business you know some
of these problems were really
insurmountable we take away the pain
from entrepreneurs by just taking
everything off their hands they don't
have to think about how the clinic
counting is going to get done you know
we just take everything and do it for
them so you know really the purpose is
just to to get them back to what they
want to be doing the most important
thing to do is start from an authentic
place I think that a lot of people try
to start companies and the idea is sort
of you know something they think that
other people will like or other people
think it should be we're not that good
at it necessarily imagining what
everyone else wants and if you're not
tapped into what you actually really
believe you know you're gonna make a
difference on it's just kind of fall
short I think the best advice of God is
not to you know forget your life it's
really easy to say oh that's something
that's gonna happen someday
you know once I've made it and done all
these things and then you find you know
the accomplishments come in and you know
there's just another one to shoot for
and then when your life gonna start the
way I balanced a young startup and young
family is you know just really have to
plan ahead and make time for
you can't just you know get too drawn
into the company which is you know
realistically the one that is really
easy to pull you in and can be really
distracting and then sort of go oops
you know I always forgot about my family
but it has to be very intentional it can
be really easy to hate you do this
meeting at you know seven o'clock at
this time and just go oh no problem you
know instead of saying well actually no
I can't because I'm going to be at home
with my family and how would we do it on
Monday you have to choose your
priorities I think that's that's what
success is